what was the first acting gig you got
mad men
that was the first gig you got that's
the big show for your first gig
i remember going on to set and like
you know kind of i had no idea that
because my my acting school was not like
four camera there was no
it was like more theater type
uh just learning how to actually act in
the craft of acting and
they and i remember like you know kind
of doing it and then coming back and
there's like all this tape on the floor
and i'm like like what
like what why why is
why is there tape why is the tape on the
floor
and they're like those are your marks
and i was like oh oh yeah yeah eisner
didn't teach me about marks no no they
didn't no same two where it was like
you know we were drinking or something
and they were like oh you need you drank
on this line and i was like oh yeah but
like
and they're like you need to every time
in the same i'm like i have to do every
time on the same line because i was so
just like i'm real and i'm in the moment
like there's no it's a lot it's it's
harder than it looks it's like you have
to do all these things script supervisor
keeps coming at you and go yes
you drank at this line hey you walked
over here when he said this your hand is
open not closed you know and so you're
like okay yeah yeah fingers here and
then like
no like and then you switched it and
you're like god damn it why did i move
so much how about i just the best take
just use [ __ ] that
it gets so frustrating yeah because and
you do it so many times and from all the
different angles and was it something
that you but you did you love it enough
and obviously you loved it enough that
you wanted to keep doing it oh i loved
it when i was even studying it i i loved
it um what was it what is it about
acting that you really love
i think i liked
the i i got to feel things i got to feel
everything anything and everything good
or bad and i
i don't not to say like
like i'm an emotional person but i'm i'm
very
i'm pretty in control of a lot of my
emotions in life
and
um can be quite even keeled and things
um and with acting it's like the
i love the up and downs
uh of of getting to feel things that you
might not get to feel in life and in in
a safe place to do it where you're not
like destroying
destroying your life by uh emotionally
losing it um
and i think for me acting always was
the
the my favorite part is when you're
when you surprise yourself and you don't
know what you're doing so like you're
you're in a scene and
some the way you respond is you surprise
yourself and that
being able to like the unpredictability
of that and just the things like coming
up it's like where did that come from
and it's like
that and which is kind of you know what
i learned in
an acting class you're doing scenes like
that all the time
and then when you're you're working in
like television it's rare you get to
kind of
those are very special moments when you
get to have scenes like that